and here's the next one oh wait what
happened in the world hey guys it's Max
Angelica and Vadim and today we are
gonna see can the iPhone 14 pro keep up
with an almost 9 000 Pro Camera yep and
Max went out and took a bunch of photos
with both of them and we don't know
which is which and we're gonna choose
the best photo so go ahead and play
along with us and let us know your
results in the comments so here is the
first one we have a top dynamic range
situation both of these are around 50
megapixels now looking at this first one
I do like the one on the left better
first of all because it looks a little
bit more sharp like looking at his hair
and I like that it's brighter with
better HDR I actually liked the one on
the right because it looked a little
more natural to me and I really like
highlight roll off all right you guys
both voted for different ones but but
Dean chose the iPhone being more
detailed and both of these were Raw
photos that were edited as well so here
is the second one this is a beautiful
sunset that we had it's got to be the
left for me just looking at that Sunset
but look at all the wheat and whatever
that is it looks so natural whereas like
you're getting all these artifacts on
the right all right you guys voted for
the Pro Camera now this is actually
using the telephoto lens so not all of
these are using that main sensor here is
a selfie shot I mean I do like on the
right how you get more detail in the
face and hair everything so I'm gonna go
with that one I agree I really like the
detail and HD on the right one it's just
way better and you guys voted for the
iPhone now both these are actually using
uh 48 and 50 megapixels that's using the
rear camera I actually spun it around
yeah yeah and that's just the natural
blur here is a tough porch portrait with
a very tough subject
okay well I have to say the right one
should we go with the right one I'm
going with the right one just because
all of this is really distracting to me
well this looks more realistic even if
it's not as like detailed or sharp well
I'm actually gonna go with the left no
way the main reason is because on the
right it feels like all this is blotched
together all of the little wheat pieces
or whatever where you can see like this
more crisp detail and separation here I
don't know I like it better I want to
hear your guys's opinion on this photo
specifically comment below and and
Jessica chose the Pro Camera again and
Vadim chose the iPhone now right here
the blur did get messed up and I tried
my best to match everything up as far as
uh the amount of blur now here is our
first video we did include a video as
well so it's a cinematic mode all right
so this is incredibly close I can't
believe that like the one of these is
the iPhone and it's doing blur insanely
well but I'm gonna choose the one on the
left I think it does very well I like
the little bokeh balls that stand out
and I like the white balance too I agree
well you guys chose the pro camera and
my mind was blown this is 8k on the pro
camera here's the next shot right here
we have 48 megapixels compared to 50
what do you think instantly the right I
mean it's the only one that's actually
like detailed and sharp the one on the
left is blurry everywhere yeah yeah all
right you guys voted for the iPhone I
can
detail has to be deep Fusion I added
sharpening to the Raw on here also
dynamic range it was a tough situation
that's in the shadows so awesome for the
iPhone there and here we have a shot of
my kids and their friend right away the
one on the right it looks so natural
like the faces highlight roll off
everything except for the dynamic range
but it's okay I'm glad you guys are not
only voting for detail because you guys
are absolutely right there here is
another shot immediately the left one to
me yeah it's got to be the left the one
on the right just looks blurry just
everywhere iPhone it's 14. and I did
stop it down but yeah Auto focusing and
that kind of stuff there wow we have a
shot of some pizza we enjoy there I've
gotta choose the one on the right for
the dynamic range because then the left
you could see it's blown out all this
cheese details blown out I had to kick
out of the iso quite a bit too because
it was dark in there it's got to be the
right for sure
I'm excited to see which one's which and
the iPhone iPhone come on a lot of the
little uh highlight details what's
retained there it's pulled back because
it's stacking multiple shots we have a
portrait shot right here okay this is
really close if you guys are having a
hard time that is amazing for the iPhone
I mean I've got to choose the left I
like the
um what's the zoom length I guess where
you see a lot more on the right side I
like it more on the left and you can see
all the micro hairs yeah stuff that's my
reasoning that's how you know those are
annoying if you're a photographer fixing
that photoshop
automatically but yes I guess shows a
pro camera we have another portrait shot
here this time a wide one the right one
all right I'm definitely choosing the
left one actually because I'm seeing a
lot more detail in like the clothing
it's very very sharp and on top of that
if you look at the concrete you actually
get the lines and the HDR comes out
where this is all blown out and it's
kind of soft that's true the right one
is blown out the reason I picked it is
because the subjects they just pop out
more to me and here the whole image the
whole lighting was very flat I had to
bring up the highlights for them not to
be crazy flat because the iPhone does
bring up highlights but it also has that
HDR alright guys we have another video
here oh
I mean it's obviously the left the left
wins the right is terrible the sky was
bright we had the sun coming out it was
a very hard HDR situation now wow all of
this that looks really good jeez all
right these iPhone one now with the Sony
that's with all of these the
stabilization sucks this is actually a
vertical video and vertical video
stabilization is horrendous I try to fix
it in post and you know the AK is just
not worth it there now one of the ways
Pro cameras always beat iPhones is audio
quality because by standard Pros will
always use either external audio
recording or use a wireless solution
like the Lark M1 for my sponsor Holly
Land Tech which plugs directly into the
camera just listen to this difference
this is the microphone quality using
just the iPhone 14 pro this is the
microphone quality of the Pro Camera
using the Lark M1 but thankfully
hollyland's brand new Lark C1 comes with
a choice of a lightning or USB type-c
port for smartphones including the cool
charging case which keeps your receiver
and transmitter charged up for up to 32
hours of battery life so you can
basically plug the receiver into your
iPhone's port and clip the transmitters
onto the shirts of your subjects which
is perfect for interviews just check out
the sound quality improvements this is
the microphone quality using just the
iPhone 14 pro this is a microphone
quality using the Lark C1 with the
iPhone this is the microphone quality
using the Lark C1 with the iPhone and
yes it sounds that good because it
supports active noise cancellation
making it the perfect Plug and Play
Audio solution for anybody recording
videos so check out both the Lark C1 and
M1 using links below for 10 off using
the code Max Tech all right we have a
macro shot here oh gosh you can only
choose the right it's the only one
that's like looks very sharp and
detailed the right one for sure I hate
how the the background is really
distracting but if we just look at the
subjects definitely the right one yeah
all right that is the iPhone this is the
macro mode with ultra wide with the Sony
I zoomed out this is at like F16 in
order to get more stuff in focus without
using a dedicated ultride macro which is
rare we have this shot right here tough
lighting lots of detail wow
with both of these I had to push the
Shadows up because they were really dark
even on the iPhone I feel like I'm
seeing a lot of detail contrast
saturation like everything just really
stands out with this whole statue or
whatever I like the right one I think
I'm gonna agree because the left one
does look a little bit flat as well so
you guys chose the Sony and I'll say
when I was editing these on one computer
looks one way on the phone looks another
way on this laptop even though it's
apple looks different as well which is
very frustrating but here we have
another selfie it's got to be the left
that looks killer like look at the
pokeballs natural blur everything It's
gotta be the left that is the Sony
um I was trying to match up the f-stops
I guess here
um I didn't this is using the front
facing camera and it looks way worse as
far as detailing other things here we
have a shot when I was walking it looked
beautiful to my eyes so I took the best
photo I could with each one huh the left
easily looks so so much better yeah I
don't really like how on the right a lot
of the detail is crushed the left is a
Sony now with the right one I use the
ultra wide because that's what my eye
saw the super tall trees but
unfortunately the ultra does not have
the 48 megapixel detailed dynamic range
with that great sensor so maybe next
year here we have a zoom shot gotta go
with the left one it has to be the left
it's much much better and you guys chose
the iPhone what now a lot of people say
you don't need a crazy telephoto yeah 50
megapixel zoom in all the way which this
is all the way and crop but the iPhone
even without the special zoom lens makes
it look better here we have a shot I
won't say what I mean it's the right
easily it's better HDR where you can see
more detail in the plane and detail
sharpness everything and we have another
one for the iPhone now here's the
original image this is a crop of the 48
megapixel and I couldn't push the HDR
that much or else everything else looked
weird whereas in the crop the iPhone
actually boosts up those highlights and
makes it look more Dynamic which is hard
to do in post here we have a portrait
shot my kids really wanted to play
Pickleball when they were watching the
left one looks very natural to me I'm
going with that one yep I'm also gonna
go with the left one because on the
right you can see some areas where the
blur just cuts out around the edges yeah
it looks a little bit weird a little off
yeah so left and there's a win for Sony
with the iPhone even though the portrait
mode is great in a situation like this
it's way too hard
here we have a shot of this tree for me
left yeah me too I love the exposure I
love how the sun is coming yeah through
the trees looks really nice see the
detail of these it's not it's true it's
not cracked yep you guys voted for the
Sony and surprisingly this shows that
not every situation the iPhone wins in
dynamic range especially when there's so
much detail there and stuff behind it
here we have a zoom shot with the far
away playground my kids wanted to play
but we couldn't we had to take photos
this one's really tough because I like
the depth of the left one however
there's a lot of areas that are blown
out here we're on the right there's more
detail you actually have
um HDR that works well there so I'm
gonna give it to the right right I'm
very surprised you guys chose the iPhone
um because there's a lot of detail it
looks a little crunchier to me but this
is a 12 megapixel lens 3x not the main
one wow and here we have the Coeur
d'Alene Resort well definitely right
right yeah a lot lot more detail very
sharp and you guys chose the iPhone this
is a crop of the 48 and 50 megapixels
once again the iPhone brings up the
highlights with its HDR even with the 48
megapixel looks great and here's a
portrait shot testing out the toughest
situation we have stuff in the
foreground and background okay the one
on the right looks
Supernatural wow I'm surprised by how
good they are because even the
foreground on both of them I know I've
got to go with the left one actually I
like that one this is insane how close
these are close I'm going with the left
all right we have the left iPhone is
what Vadim chose that's good
this makes me happy that I shoot most of
my photos with an iPhone here's a more
normal standard shot with some HDR man
they're so similar but I'm going with
the left simply because
of I don't know the better exposure it's
brighter the carousel sign with the
highlights I like it the
but they're really similar and that is
the iPhone
once again now a shot for my watch it's
the right it's the right easily like
look at all the texture everything nice
and focused that's nice
that is the iPhone come on what's going
on I'm using the macro mode wow and this
is inside uh this shot right here
doesn't look detailed because I have to
do a ton of denoising because it was
like ISO I don't know 20 000 wow or
something like that
um and yeah here we have a tough
lighting situation at church it's got to
be the right one just all the detail
that's a good point if you look at the
right you see all the people that are
actually sharp details here it's all
just blurry and smeared out yeah it's
the right that one is the iPhone once
again
but what about this one okay left left
look at that yep better HDR like nice
and natural I love that actually no HDR
because that is the Sony
um the iPhone with that telephoto it
can't compete the previous shot right
here this is 48 megapixel raw edited
with deep Fusion all of that stuff but
the zoom the Sony's way better now we
have this portrait shot in low light
okay
I've got to go with the right I like the
colors that pop out more and I like the
more natural blur where you could see a
bunch of issues with the blur here
really stands out the Sony right there
you can't beat real blur it can never
mess up we have a shot of Noah here
outside mean Muggin yeah he was actually
if he doesn't look excited to take
photos he was
I'm gonna go with the left even though
some of the areas are better on the
right like the background I like how his
face is more bright and looks even more
sharp too yeah the subject definitely
matters yeah left you guys chose the
iPhone now as I said I edited all of
these to be as close as I could they
look different on this laptop now but
with the Sony I was risking blowing that
out it's already blown out more so so if
I wanted to bring up his face everything
else got messed up unless I want to use
a bunch of brushes in Photoshop where's
the iPhone automatically brings up the
face with their processing we have a
shot of a flag here this is a zoom shot
the right I gotta go with the right I
like how the colors pop more the white
balance and in general yeah I like the
right one I like how it stands out I
like the whole cut out even though this
might be a little mess up I am surprised
you guys chose the iPhone now with this
shot and a lot of these shots I just
took an instant shot with the iPhone and
I'm done with the Sony I would take four
five six and here the flag was moving so
I had to go up to like ISO 20 000 and do
a faster shutter speed or else it'd be
smeared then I have to use denoising
contrast all of that stuff where the
iPhone is just one click here's another
shot of Noah insanely tough situation
edited definitely oh gosh okay the
flaring is really annoying oh no but
definitely the right one I mean oh like
just looking at his hand
all of this what is that noise
yeah it has to be the right because just
the noise in artifact it just kills the
color everything just gets destroyed and
you guys chose the iPhone once again now
some people complained and I did at
first that the iPhone even in raw at
night it doesn't do 48 megapixels it
over samples it does denoising but in
this instance both these photos were
super dark at first and the iPhone
allowed me to bring up more so without
having artifacts than the actual Sony
and now we have another video this time
at night let's take a look I mean if you
just judge by the HDR alone like this is
all blown out
that rock everything like you get so
much more detail and hdr on the right
what I noticed first is actually some of
this noise on the right one so which one
are you guys gonna
just for the end still going with the
right they're right Angelica I'll go
with the left left Vadim chose the
iPhone once again and Angelica chose uh
the Sony now I added to the Sony to get
the best dynamic range but the iPhone
Stacks multiple images to get the best
HDR even though it is more noisy and
here's the next one
potato
yes we have a big difference here what
are you guys choosing what do you think
oh this looks amazing that looks awesome
I don't know what happened there I don't
know much about like cameras but I can't
imagine how either of them could do that
yeah I'll tell you this is brought up a
lot oh okay okay so left guys this blew
my mind and yes the iPhone one yeah
the iPhone I took I pressed it once it
was a three second exposure it was Pitch
Black outside that looks good the Sony
no I took like six seven shots I had to
switch to manual focus because it
wouldn't focus it was so dark this is
ISO 64
000 using a one one tenth of a second
shutter wow because of how dark it was
and then once I edit it this is the best
I can get yeah now this is using a ton
of denoising if I got rid of all this
noise he was a smear this was the best
balance and this is not a usable photo
which the iPhone can create Magic with
lights autofocus it is insane here's our
next shot right here it's the right dang
to me the right one just looks over
sharpened and a little fake I'm going to
left I chose Vadim loves the iPhone
photos over sharpened I mean this is HDR
looks natural but that's just over and
sharper that's okay
here's a tough dynamic range shot I've
got to choose the right I have to choose
the right as well I mean look at that
it's got better detail and you're not
blowing out the entire chair cushion so
yeah that's all blown out and then like
the flag is like way more visible yeah
right
you guys show us the iPhone yes the
dynamic range is better because of the
processing uh here's the original shot
on the Sony so I shot multiple ones and
chose the best and edited but it's just
tough without stacking images here's the
next one right here it was crazy dark
outside I mean with this one I've got to
go with the right because the left looks
like it tried to make it Daylight it's
way too bright those clouds look funky
yeah it's got to be the right here the
Sony wins there's a lot more noise in
the Sony I did add denoising you could
push the noising more but it's stacking
versus denoising and here is the other
one here this is on a tripod I I have to
say the left one because of the sky look
at all the stars I agree the left one
actually has a range of colors where the
right is all like greenish unless I'm
colorblind but it all looks like one
color pretty blue
Stars can get messed up if you have a
lot of clouds and we did where this was
a slower shutter speed high ISO but I
could still denoise it well all right
now here is the neck shot oh
this must be a big crop
it's got to be the right easily
I guess so
it was the iPhone once again
who wanted to test out because at night
mode it's no longer 48 megapixel it gets
been like apple showed into a 12
megapixel so I thought the detail would
be way worse but on the Sony if it's
that dark underexposed had to be edited
you don't see a lot of that detail
anyway so I guess apple is making the
right choice doing that and that one is
the last shot we had a mix of photos and
videos
all right guys go ahead and let us know
your thoughts down below you guys see
him excited our shop yeah with that what
did you guys think was gonna happen I
thought the iPhone would get smoked like
it does every year absolutely I thought
it would get smoke too but I was really
surprised by that brand new sensor and
the Rockies if you're not shooting raw
you need to be shooting Rock because
without that this would not happen all
right guys uh Vadim what did you get I
go first oh my goodness I mean Oregon uh
okay now you go first yeah okay I got 25
for the iPhone only 13 for the Pro
Camera oh my goodness okay
that's crazy and I got 19 for the iPhone
and 19 for the Pro Camera 50 50. no way
I got 50 50. 50 50. and honestly I did
not expect this either there were times
where the iPhone just did a better job
because of diffusion because of the raw
and because of the 48 megapixels the
sensor is way better than Samsung's if
you guys have not seen the comparison of
Samsung it will blow your mind it's
right over there click that video click
about to subscribe and we will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]